[Music]
if it was up to you and you were the
mayor of a town yes make it small like
like a village is smaller than a town
I'll make gambling legal sure what's
what state what state in which town you
make it up the point is what's my
ethnicity background you can make that
up the point is Jamar if you were the
mayor of this town and you were in
charge of coming up with a creative way
of getting people to stay indoors I
would lock up only the Asian people
well well the man that's Steve city and
in that sport rifle is shut down Oh
Jamal Jamal eeeh uh we don't have corona
don't exist
you found an anodite you guys guys you
guys get rid of it yup good job you shot
everybody
Mona Jason Momoa disease disease it's
like can I catch that Geoff once told me
that she would lick his his motorcycle
seat I would really she said that in a
pre rona environment do you stand by it
now I stand by it
he had the Rona's I would buy freeway he
farted all over that seat on the five
freeway Oh inhale it Wow
what would you guys do to keep people in
yeah to keep them inside their home ours
are our Empire we have very good
citizens and I would ma I would go after
the good old Chinese which is taped
their door shut and if anyone breaks
their seal China they taped all the
doors and if if the seal was broken they
would get in trouble but for us it's
just execution the top scientists to all
stand at the podium at the White House
and they would say this did this disease
it makes guys dicks smaller and nobody
would [ __ ] doubt it promise you I
promise yeah and but just to show that I
am a merciful and loving leader its
execution if you broke the seal but if
you complete the whole process it's a
month supply of blow jobs complete
likely inside yeah
that's a [ __ ] yeah oh we have a harem
of elite caregivers and I heard they
love their job they love their work
mm-hmm genders yeah it'll be [ __ ] in
and and pussy-eating it'll it'll it'll
it's called the oral Factory
it's a strange sound like a real website
oral fact it's just yeah there was
it's the oral fourth yes oh I like that
you know the SWAT team okay you know
what I do is a guy running away from
know there's girls like with capes and
her titties just jiggling out there I
don't like a guy stick stick in the
toilet hit the flush that's great oh
yeah I wish porn could be that creative
it can be literally that's sure that's
sure have you enjoying you for other
reasons that [ __ ] concepts but it's
so poorly produced honey would they
deliver pizza with a dick inside the box
you know that's pretty clever do you
know what the Pirates porn movie yeah it
was the King like 2001 I think the most
expensive yeah it cost like tens of
millions it was the boss Expo is it that
difficult especially today in today's
day and age like everyone like you you
just be an iPhone you can create a
better content
I'll be honest don't you skip that [ __ ]
I skip the story
let's see that's why I'm gonna take a
good part I'm gonna change the game and
have porn with great story you'll be the
first yeah I'm happy first there's the
six of these guys every five years or
like I'm gonna change porn forever we're
gonna make the actually a good one yeah
that's Burt Reynolds whole character
Boogie Nights is my favorite anyway the
reason why I bring that up is because a
village in Indonesia have decided to
have volunteers youth volunteers dress
up as these they're called pokum or a
shrouded ghost which are legendary
figures believed to represent the souls
of dead people trapped in their funeral
shrouds you have seen this video so this
is how there's volunteers out and about
this village oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
hopping around scurrying the villagers
so they can stay inside so we are they
on a break right now turn like on a
lunch break just chilling I think
another 15 minutes guys [ __ ] putting
this cigarette into the 15 minute break
how many people did you scare today
that's five that's like Hornet Horror
Nights like in the break room like
[ __ ] zombie head on like there's a
[ __ ] knife to his head yeah okay let
me show you guys a video clip scaring
people what if they need to go pee Larry
actually I know it wasn't there they're
just jamming out and playing guitar a
little same three guys Maria yeah I
think I need to get the the calm with
injury is that people were coming out of
their house to take selfies with the
initial problem
dude that last one was the most [ __ ]
reaction ever that was totally [ __ ]
fake they need to get better actors
there's porn actors better than that
yeah sure that looks like like 2008
YouTube sketches like one of our old
videos yes so they're saying it is
working now though cuz initially yeah it
was more like it wasn't scary before but
now it is scary I guess
oh they're saying that for the past
three days when they were interviewed
that there were no residents seem going
out at night and apparently it's because
they're scared of the fake ghosts they
paying for these guys to know they
volunteer oh they're volunteers
they'll be so funny would you like to
work as a ghost for the city actually
the you these youth volunteers went to
the mayor
and convinced the mayor to say yes to
this like here's what you do you'd think
the sort of the media in Steve City we
would do this you biggest order the
meeting Steve City yep you leak a story
the media that says that there's a
sniper who's gone rogue and he's killing
people who are in public and people
would stay the [ __ ] inside that sounds
pretty real now and some did that [ __ ]
in DC when the DC sniper [ __ ] happened I
remember I remember everybody was scared
to be outside during that they big
leaked the story or it could happen in
there well it was real really oh god are
you saying they've leaked the story and
it was really I would leak i would leak
a fake story I remember um one day I was
coming home I parked my car and I got
out and in the helicopter would like and
he was he was on a loudspeaker he was
like citizens of Monterey Park there was
our man a dangerous man loose stay in
your residence stay in your residence
and I was like oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] around
inside
open up door closed and locked it and I
was like damn dude what if somebody was
out there and he was looking for
somebody to like let me get in your car
and suck your dick or something yeah and
then when you got inside no force and
when he got inside you took your butcher
knife and you put it back in your knife
rack it was me I got inside my [ __ ]
took my
and I was like crazy guy I know who is
our man never have a school lockdown
because of that because of the we had
school lock downs from bomb threats but
not any like armed threats no rid drill
we had like false alarms they were like
oh there's somebody who's dangerous
outside Auto campus and then they would
lock down the classrooms well wasn't it
like now where they have only active
shooter drill
yeah that's insane it was much more
generic yeah same cuz I can I was in
elementary school I remember we had a
lockdown because there was someone in
the neighborhood that was the stranger
no they were being chased by cops oh and
they were just like oh you guys all had
the same saying I was like I remember
like seeing the helicopter yeah we did
active shooter drills when I was in
middle school yeah that was right after
Columbine so then I don't think they
were afraid of scaring kids then like I
think nowadays the they're afraid of
using that con language and [ __ ] but
like yeah that that we did actors
tougher back then that's what was it was
a difference huh because they are doing
that no no well yeah but you said that
you hadn't had that happen like drill
like it was like a generic exactly they
don'ts call it that they do that but
they don't call it back then they're
like there is an active shooter on
campus active shooter drill kick and
then yet so they were they just said all
that [ __ ] these days they use like
euphemisms and stuff right before the
guy is gonna come and rape everybody but
nada but oh there's a problematic person
outside it could be very problematic
yeah well I mean if they were going
around the city and making those
announcements do you think you guys
would leave your house especially used
to either you just think I gotta drive
around the block first first oh it was
for real like that yeah yeah they said
there's a sniper round the loser
I'm staying inside I wouldn't do it a
little bit like when I when I went
driving in the rain during Rona I just I
didn't get on the car didn't go anywhere
I mean yeah hey that's quarantine still
right yeah cuz you're not interacting
with anyone
ya didn't talk to one person didn't see
one person nothin are people even
pulling I mean cops pulling people over
for driving around for no reason how
would they know that you're doing it for
no reason though
I think I've only heard about it and
they like it's not like a checkpoint but
that's it
cuz I did see people posting on Twitter
so I honestly I it's not credible but
there were people saying like yeah the
girlfriend of mine her sister just got a
ticket it's always like two three steps
away it's always like exactly so then
they're like they got like a $300 ticket
in LA because she was coming home from
her boyfriend's house and it wasn't an
essential need and she ended up getting
a ticket I don't know how true that is
but I heard like some cities though you
get fined for not wearing face masks and
[ __ ] like that yes a lot of [ __ ] we're
like moms are getting arrested at
playgrounds and [ __ ]
most of the playgrounds I Drive by
they're all like taped up and stuff
constructions you guys see how they
filled in the Venice Beach skate skate
with sand sand yeah and then a lot a
bunch of dirt bikers just came over and
like [ __ ] you and they started using the
money they spend on that by the way my
god well they move this in well no they
they had a dump truck [ __ ] dumped it
you can grind you're not I think what
she feeds that it's not standing far
away it's just like right but how much
how much money is it to get the guy
there and all the [ __ ] here's like an
empty spot in the beach bunch of skate
parks got so sad - oh yeah it's all over
little kids are going out there and like
playing like at sandbox right that's fun
too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]